Clau enables rich vr interactions in a
compact handheld free-moving device with
claw you can grasp ritual objects and
feel appropriate forces during grasping
you can also touch and feel the shape of
a virtual object as well as get
resistance when you push on them
you can also rub virtual surfaces and
feel their texture rendered underneath
your fingertip finally you can also feel
the recoil when shooting the virtual
weapon claw is a unique multifunctional
haptic controller that enables grasping
touching
surface texture rendering
and shooting feedback by reading the
thumb position using a proximity sensor
our controller changes its haptic mode
between grasping and touching
we use a force center located at the
fingertip mount to enable closed loop
force feedback control system with a
servo motor the servo motor only reacts
to the forces exerted by the index
finger with the closed loop force
control we can render variable stiffness
for example users can grab and feel
solid virtual objects but also soft
deformable virtual objects a voice coil
actuator at the fingertip generates
different patterns of vibration which
are used for texture rendering
coupled with the 3d hand tracking data
the voice coil actuator vibrates only
when the user moves their hand when
shooting the servo motor moves back and
forth quickly to simulate recoil
sensation in summary the clock
controller integrates multiple haptic
technologies into a vr controller device
capable of rendering compelling force
feedback while grasping touching and
shooting in virtual reality